all right as i have been saying i am not
a doctor i'm not going to play one on tv
or radio
no medical diagnosis whatsoever but is
there something democrats
know about joe biden something his
campaign knew about that they weren't
telling and aren't telling we the
american people
we played you clips from biden four
years ago
eight years ago compared them to today
and
yeah i think the author of the book
lucky was right jonathan was right
saying yeah he lost his fastball like
after tommy john's surgery and if he
ever had a slow pitch i would argue he
lost that
you decide he sent me two letters saying
by the way can you send me some stimulus
money for companies here in the state of
wisconsin
we sent millions of dollars play the
radio
make sure the television excuse me make
sure you have the record player on at
night
the the phone make sure the kids hear
words now they got a new plan
trust me it's not going to cost you any
more folks
follow your instincts on this one we
hold these truths to be self-evident
all men and women created by the goal
you know the you know the thing
they put one foot in front of the other
they keep going
that's the unbreakable spirit of the
people of america
that's who we are and representatives
uh cheryl shirley jackson lee
al green sylvia garcia lizzie pinelli
excuse me pinell and uh what am i doing
here
i'm going to lose track here what am i
doing here
and by the way it's not shirley it's
sheila jackson lee
been in office well over a whopping 40
days has not held the press conference
uh although press secretary jensachi
said today that we can expect one maybe
by the end of the month
no date for the state of the union here
with reaction former white house adviser
stephen miller an
author of they never let a crisis go to
waste fox news contributor jason
chaffetz
stephen you write a lot of speeches i
watch
donald trump i'll even say this i watch
bernie sanders
they are full of passion and energy and
engaged and there is there's no question
they are strong they are forceful
they're mentally alert they're on their
game
it's not about age it's about
aging i guess and some differences your
take
well it's customary at this point in the
presidency to issue your first address
to a joint session of congress
so the question has to be asked why is
it that we're in march
and joe biden hasn't done that yet i
think one of the reasons is actually
deceptively simple
if you look at joe biden's campaign
speeches he often read from a giant
jumbotron
not the normal teleprompters that most
politicians would use the two small
panes of glass to your left and your
right
he would read off of a giant screen in
front of him like a movie theater
like the opening scroll on star wars
giant words coming down
i actually think logistically they're
trying to figure out how can we get a
giant jump rotron into the well of
congress so that joe biden can give a
speech
i secondly think it's a stamina issue if
you look at his convention speech
it was one of the shortest in history i
think they're seriously concerned about
whether joe biden could actually deliver
a conventional hour-long state of the
union without losing all of his energy
about 20 minutes into it
i don't know you know look jason the
hardest
job for donald trump beyond what stephen
did and he worked
he did a great job all the four years he
was there
was being the teleprompter operator
because he never stays on teleprompter
steven could attest to that
it's actually the hardest job for people
working on my show and i have the best
teleprompter operator in the country
but i don't exactly usually stay on
script either i'm constantly ad-libbing
i'm i've been in radio 33 years
so i don't see joe has that strength or
ability
thoughts well first donald trump should
have won awards for his openness
transparency
and accessibility you could hear
directly what he was thinking all the
time they have been hiding joe biden for
a long period of time
joe biden of old was notorious for
talking on and on and on when i was in
congress i went to the white house
and sat right next to him in a meeting
where he talked for an hour and a half
straight
but i don't think he can string you know
12 sentences together
and have the energy to actually take
questions and go to the next topic
and that should scare a lot of people
because we don't know who the puppeteers
are
we know that ron klain is the chief of
staff is exceptionally powerful
but so are behind the scenes people like
susan rice and brian dees and some of
these other people
doing things with kamala harris that we
never see
and get exposed to and i think the media
needs to do its job and the bite
administration
needs to come clean on who's really
running that place
they did it they asked the question of
reagan reagan steve miller
they asked the question to mccain and it
seems like and they were
originally criticizing me for daring to
ask the question of joe biden
i think if that's fair for reagan and
mccain it's fair for joe
um will more people start to raise the
question do you think
it's the most important question in
america right now sean
i mean congressman shaffe has just
reeled off a few names and there's many
more
who's running this country all right
stephen miller jason chaffetz thank you
both
more hannity right